this video is sponsored by the american
lung cancer screening initiative lung
cancer is the leading cause of
cancer-related death in the world but
lung cancer screening can save lives
click the link below to learn more
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lung cancer this
video will help you understand more
about lung cancer and how it affects
your body
your lungs are a pair of organs inside
your chest that allow you to breathe
you inhale oxygen which all cells need
then you exhale a waste gas called
carbon dioxide
this gas exchange happens inside tiny
air sacs in your lungs
lung cancer is a disease in which normal
lung cells change into harmful abnormal
cells called cancer cells
cancer cells multiply to form clusters
called tumors
these tumors grow and destroy healthy
lung tissue
lung cancer may spread to other parts of
your body through blood or lymph fluid a
natural substance that helps gather
unwanted waste material from your body
there are two main types of lung cancer
small cell lung cancer and non-small
cell lung cancer they are named for the
kinds of cells in the cancer and how
they look under a microscope
non-small cell lung cancer is the most
common type of lung cancer
small cell lung cancer is the most
aggressive type of lung cancer it grows
and spreads more quickly
the most important risk factor for lung
cancer is smoking
other risk factors include breathing
second-hand smoke
exposure to radon
having a family history of lung cancer
hiv infection
exposure to harmful chemicals such as
asbestos
and air pollution
lung cancer may have no symptoms in its
early stages
when symptoms do appear they may include
chronic cough chest pain
trouble breathing coughing up blood
hoarseness
loss of appetite trouble swallowing
weight loss
tiredness and facial or neck swelling
if you have lung cancer your doctor will
need to determine the stage or
progression of the disease to help plan
your treatment
non-small cell lung cancer has many
stages
in the occult stage cancer cells are
found only in lung fluids
in stage 0 abnormal or cancer cells are
found in the lining of the airways
by stage 1 a small tumor is found
then in stage 2 the cancer has grown or
spread to nearby lymph nodes or non-lung
tissues
in stage 3a the tumor has grown to any
size in addition cancer is found in
lymph nodes on the same side of the
chest
or in nearby organs
stage 3b is similar to 3a but in 3b
cancer is found in lymph nodes on the
opposite side of the chest cancer may
also be found in lymph nodes above the
collar bone
in stage 4 tumors might be found in both
lungs
additionally cancer may have spread to
distant organs
there are fewer stages for small cell
lung cancer
in its limited stage cancer is found in
one side of the chest only
in the extensive stage cancer has spread
to the other side of the chest or to
distant organs
as you deal with a diagnosis of lung
cancer continue to talk to your doctor
and your cancer care team